- I didn't even say Happy New Year's
cause it's New Year's already
so did you make any resolutions?
- Well yes, except I did this thing,
speaking of podcasts, I
listen to this podcast
called 10 Things to Tell You
and they help you with setting goals
and being mindful in your life.
So last year, in October,
she said how about we set a goal
to finish our New Year's
resolution for next year
by the end of this year
so we start off the new year in success
rather than feeling
like we're in a deficit
so I did it.
- You did?
- I did.
- I love that.
- I set a goal to de-clutter my house
and I had three months to do it,
October, November, December.
I cleaned out my garage and my basement.
- Your closet.
- My closet.
- And the kitchen drawers.
- All the tupperware.
- Oh no.
- And I feel changed, like
it's been a good year.
- I love doing that, it's so therapeutic.
I just go in my closet and go, don't care,
don't care, don't care, get out of here,
I'm just like yeah.
I think it's emotionally helpful.
- It is, it's like a cleanse.
- Did you set one?
- Well, I no.
(laughs)
Listen, every year I say the same thing,
which is I'm going to
learn a new language.
- That's mine, oh my God, that's mine!
- You legitimately just scared me.
- No, I'm so sorry.
- Cause I was like what?
- I can't even believe you just,
that's mine.
That is mine, mine is to learn Spanish.
17 years later, hola.
(audience laughs)
So I'm now got to do a lingual Babbel,
I'm trying everything, Rosetta Stone,
none of these stones or
anything are helping me.
- I got Rosetta Stone one time,
one year I was like,
I'm gonna learn French
and I got Rosetta Stone and
as far as I got was like,
(speaks a phrase in French)
and then I do an impression which no one,
I shouldn't do,
but I was in France for
two weeks and I was like,
eh puh eh, como deta,
and like, nobody wants that.
- I did French once and all
I got every time was no.
- Nah, nah.
- Every time I said it,
I didn't do it properly.
And she'd go no, no.
And I was like you know what, I hate you.
I'm gonna name you
Francesca and I hate you.